este documento publicado por la oficina
de la dirección de inteligencia de eeuu
este 26 de febrero reavivó las tensiones
por el caso de jamalca show y el informe
que señala el príncipe heredero saudita
mohamed bin salman de haber aprobado la
operación para acabar con la vida del
reportero de 59 años indica que el
control absoluto de las organizaciones
de inteligencia y seguridad del reino
hacen que sea altamente improbable que
funcionarios sauditas pudieran asesinar
a kajouji sin la autorización de bin
salman sin embargo no se emitieron
sanciones contra el príncipe solo
restricciones de visado contra 76
sauditas señalados de estar implicados
en amenazas a disidentes en el
extranjero esto como parte de una nueva
política conocida como la prohibición
cacho kings que buscará rendición de
cuentas para quienes ataquen a
disidentes y periodistas
reconocemos nuestros compromisos y
también respetamos el derecho y la
responsabilidad de nuestro gobierno de
aclarar el contexto más amplio de la
relación bilateral entre eeuu
arabia saudita
en reacción a la publicación del informe
la relatora especial de la onu sobre
ejecuciones extrajudiciales señaló que
ahora eeuu debe tomar la iniciativa para
garantizar la rendición de cuentas sobre
el crimen pido al gobierno de arabia
saudita que revele si sus restos fueron
destruidos en el lugar o cómo y dónde
fueron eliminados las personas
responsables conocen muy bien los
detalles y ante el silencio desmedido de
arabia saudita la comunidad
internacional debe ejercer presión para
que revele los hechos frente a las
acusaciones contra bin salman el
ministerio de exteriores saudita
reaccionó a través de un comunicado
divulgado por la agencia de prensa del
reyno que califica como falsas
inaceptables e inexactas las
conclusiones del reporte